RONY ROZEN: Imagine
you've released your app
in the United States,
and it's an instant hit.
Tons of users, rave
reviews, the works.
You're now feeling
confident enough
to release your app worldwide.
But when you do,
the feedback you get
isn't nearly as positive
as you expected.
What gives?
Join us as we try to get
to the bottom of this
on this episode of "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what happened, and what could
you have done to prevent it?
It's quite simple, actually.
Many users prefer apps
in their native language.
In order for your app to
succeed in non-English speaking
countries, you need
to localize it.
The more languages you
support, the bigger
your potential target
population gets.
If you didn't do the
initial prep work required
for localizing your app from the
start, this may take some time,
and is prone to errors.
But if you spend just
a little bit of time
preparing your app for
localization from the start,
you'll save yourself a
lot of time in the future.
Not yet convinced it's
worth the extra effort?
Let me show you just how
easy it is to add support
for localization if you plan it
right and do it from the start.
Let's go over a few key rules.
One, add NSLocalized
string to any string,
and I mean any string,
that display to your users.
And yes, that even includes that
OK button text on that alert.
This doesn't require you to
provide the actual translations
in any language.
Just wrap the text with
NSLocalized string,
preparing it to be translated
to various languages
in the future.
Two, make sure to add support
for localization right
from the start.
This will save you time,
and prevent potential errors
as you move forward with
localizing your app.
If you don't do
this from the start,
and then find yourself
wanting to add localization
to your app, you'll find
yourself going over your code,
searching for strings,
and wrapping them
with NSLocalized string.
There's a relatively
high probability
of missing something,
or adding localization
to something that shouldn't be
localized, like a file name,
for example.
So save yourself the extra
wasted time down the line
and localize all your
strings from the start.
Three, always set text
displayed to the user via code.
Try to avoid setting the
text in Interface Builder,
even if it's a text
that doesn't change
throughout the entire
life cycle of the app,
like the OK button
text on that alert.
These texts and
all others should
be set via code so they
can be easier to localize.
Four, there is no need to worry
about the actual translations
at this point.
And that's what makes
this process so painless.
You're just preparing
the app to be
easily localized in the future.
You'll have enough time to worry
about the actual translations
later.
Sounds easy, right?
Told ya.
So this is how you used to
set your labels text via code.
This is how you'll do it now.
The method takes two values.
One is the key.
For now, we'll
simply use the string
that we actually want to
be presented to the user.
The other is a comment.
Many developers tend to
ignore the comment parameter.
They either leave it blank, or
use the same value as the key.
This is not the right way
to treat this parameter.
The truth is that it's almost
as important as the key,
and you should give it
the attention it deserves.
The goal of the comment is
to provide the translator
with all the context he
or she needs in order
to translate the key string
in the best possible way.
This comment is all
that the translator
will know about
the string, and may
improve the quality of the
localized version of your app.
It's a shame not
to use it properly.
When your app is ready
to be translated,
meaning all of the
strings are set via code
and use NSLocalized
string, there
are several ways of generating
the strings file translation.
We'll use this terminal script.
This will locate all uses
of NSLocalized string
throughout the code,
and will generate
the strings file,
which you'll be
able to send to the translator.
The file will be made out
of sections like this,
one for each relevant string.
The comment is
actually the value
you provided for the comment
parameter of NSLocalized
string.
As you can see, this
is the only context
the translator has about where
or when the string is displayed
so that it may affect
the translation.
It's even more important that
the string can be interpreted
in more than one way.
On the left side of the
equation, you'll see the key.
Unless you do
anything else, this
is what will be
displayed to the user.
The right side of the equation
contains a translation
for this string.
This is what the
translator would
change to the actual
translation of the key
in the relevant language.
The file you get back
from the translator
should contain
translations for all
of the strings in
the same structure,
and in only one
language per file.
If you want to support multiple
languages, which you're
very encouraged to do,
you need to have one file
for each supported language.
So now that you have one
or more localization files
for the different languages
you want your app to support,
what do you do with them?
Good question.
All localization files should
be named localizable.strings.
The way we can tell them
apart is by the folder
they'll be placed in.
For English, the folder
name will be en.lproj.
For Spanish, it'll be es,
and for Chinese it'll be zh.
You probably get
the point by now.
The folder name should be
the two-letter representation
of the language you want to
support, followed by dot lproj.
Testing different localizations
is pretty straightforward.
Once you added the
various localization
files and their folders
to your Xcode target,
run the app on your device,
or on the simulator, if you
prefer, and change
the device's language
by going to Settings, General,
Language and Region, iPhone
Language, and selecting the
language you want to test.
Just make sure that you remember
how to change the language back
once you're done testing.
Reading the menu options
is slightly harder
when they're written in a
language you don't understand.
So now you know how to add
basic support for localization
to your app.
But what more do you
need to do in order
to make sure users from
different countries or cultures
are getting the most
out of your app?
What if the same word
in English should
be translated to different
words in different scenarios
in other languages?
Are there other ways to
generate the strings files?
Great questions.
Join us on the next
episode of "Route 85"
for more localization
tips and tricks.
Until then, I'm Rony Rozen.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]